[Musique]
chaque année la martinique importe près
2 millions 400 mille bouteilles de
champagne un chiffre qui
proportionnellement à sa population
enfin l'un des plus gros consommateurs
au monde
il produit également l'un des meilleurs
hommes de la planète
régulièrement primés dans les concours
internationaux la martinique également
réputé pour ses traditions festives et
souvent bien arrosées
un cocktail détonnant qui lui confère
une image parfois sulfureuse mais qu'en
est il vraiment les martiniquais
consomme-t-il plus d'alcool qu'ailleurs
selon les cas les nuances sont
nombreuses et des études réalisées
tordeux bien souvent le cou aux idées
reçues
[Musique]